[Music]
hello and welcome to this ai coffee
break
recently we have seen how transformers
are being applied not only on text but
on images or
even on both combined how is this
possible
aren't images and text so different we
read
text from left to right and images are
something that we perceive at once
or do we in this video we will explain
why images and text can be similar in
the eyes
of a transformer neural network and
point out
what really makes images and text
different
difference that could make the
transformer stumble
on the representation level what is
text text is a sequence of characters or
words
and it's a sequence because we read from
left to right
in english but neural networks do not
work
directly with characters nor with text
neural networks work with points
determined by coordinates or
numbers in high dimensional spaces
neural networks are great
at squeezing stretching and bending the
input space
so that the similar data points get
close together
and are easy to discriminate from the
similar data points
so the transformers working with numbers
request that characters or words are
encoded into
vectors these vectors are ordered
preserving the sequence structure of the
text
there are neural architectures like the
lstm
where this order is captured
intrinsically by the architecture
the lstm looks at every word vector one
after the other
but the transformer works on sets looks
at everything in parallel
so for the transformer to know this
order
positional embeddings are added to the
vectors
the vectors can be initialized with
numbers where words belonging together
are already together or they can be
one-hot encodings or
token identifiers it is always
up to the loss constrained neural
network to figure out a better
inner representations where words
belonging together
are shifted closer to each other and
that was it for text
the rest is transformer magic check out
our video explaining how the transformer
works
linked below then what are images
grayscale
images are a matrix of numbers a high
number corresponds to a high light
intensity in that region
a low number is a darker spot for
color images we just have a stack of
three of these matrices
each corresponding to the red blue and
green channel
a high number in the red matrix
corresponds to a high intensity of red
light
but once the image is stored the
computer has
these three matrices and the color is
not exactly there
anymore the computer would not notice if
we would just
exchange the numbers between these
matrices color
occurs again in your monitor if there is
a high value in the matrix
labeled with red it will emit light with
the certain light frequency that we call
red so let's look at the word vectors
again if we take their sequence and put
them
one under the other we have an image
crazy right let's undo this and do
something different instead
take the image and treat it like a
sequence of rows
and this idea is not even that crazy it
is exactly how
cathode ray tube screens in all tvs and
old
monitors treated this matrix as a
sequence by
drawing the image from left to right and
from top to bottom
in this way the representation of text
and images
is the same the text is a sequence of
word vectors the image is a sequence of
image vectors
we can add positional embeddings and the
transformer is ready to process text or
images
individually or both at the same time
for multi-modal integration
and the transformer can process them
quite efficiently because computations
are in parallel on this set of vectors
which is not really a sequence it's a
set the
sequentiality is quite artificially
encoded in these positional embeddings
in this way the transformers kind of
butcher the way we humans
thought about text and images we are
comfortable with the lstm's inductive
bias of looking at one word
after the other so why is the
transformer looking at everything at the
same time
well i do not know about you but for me
when i'm reading out loud i have to peek
much further away into the sequence to
get the right intonation
i also peek into the past by short-term
memorization which is
honestly better than the memory of the
lstm we are also
comfortable with cnns that do a very
similar kind of processing
as what happens in our eyes but applying
this kind of
biological inspiration on neural
networks and
restricting their solution space with
biases is also
unfair to them it is important to take
as much inspiration from the biological
optimization algorithm
especially when it comes to energy
efficiency but we should also look
beyond
like with the transformer that is free
of the lstm and cnn
inductive biases okay so we have seen
that images and text can be represented
the same and the transformer heavily
takes advantage of this but
if images and text are represented
equally does that
make them equal well no images and texts
are not
born equal therefore they become very
different
content-wise vision is often an
evolutionary necessity
and evolved independently in many
species language human stroke of genius
came
later after humans already had their
vision
being invented it is based upon many
agreed upon rules therefore text is in a
way
already compressed it omits a lot of
stuff
we do not say that the grass is green if
it is
a visual common knowledge also in the
data sets transformers are usually
trained on
there is little if no figurative speech
and there are very few ways to say
for example cat in english language in
contrast
images of cats can look very very
different from each
angle camera setting and so on so
omission of the visual information in
language the
necessary and somewhat arbitrary rules
of language
cultures and languages are few of the
many
things that make text and images quite
different in content
there is overlap but they are also
complementary
and miss coffee bean thinks that this is
so exciting that the representations and
the processing is similar but the
content and nature of text and images
are so different when the transformer
acts on language we sometimes do not see
the language phenomena because of so
much transformer complexity
and the other times we do not see the
transformer because of so much
language so it's more than helpful to
learn something about transformers
text and images by seeing them interact
in different constellations
it's more or less like a complicated
ablation study
and the takeaway for multimodal
integration of all these
three together is that even if text and
images
are represented the same they are not
equal
in their content giving transformer
models a hard time to integrate them
the tendency is to kind of ignore the
visual information and rely
on the text because text is already so
compressed
and its biases are more easy to be
picked up
to find out more about this vision and
language inequality and its effects on
multimodal learning check out our video
about this link below
in any case miss coffee bean gets out of
here now
right hey miss coffee bean miss coffee
bean miss coffee bean come
okay bye
[Music]
you